[Music]
son I'm so excited because your
real-life love the lovely Sarah Hyland
it's coming in from mysterious guest
spot what I know that's a what can you
tease about her role that everyone fell
in love with at onset the cast the crew
it was a real joy to have Iran said
she's been with us since you know season
one obviously coming to visit me and
having a lot of set as an actress with
no I'm sorry it's shared apparently how
special was it for you to be able to
have her in your one defense it was one
point of what's nice about it is when we
get to set it wasn't it wasn't so much
boyfriend-girlfriend it was two actors
working together and we got to separate
that and work with each other which was
really nice and very professional I
can't have to mention any of that sort
of stuff
yeah it was really wonderful one of the
things that our et readers love so much
about Sarah is that she's not afraid to
stand up to all the social media bullies
on there she recently really stood up
for herself how proud were you of her
incredibly proud and like you know as
the public knows Sarah's going through
quite a bit at the moment and for anyone
to be small-minded enough to try and
enclose her into a space that they just
don't understand I think is ridiculous
so I think the way she deals with it is
is incredible because you know people
need to understand more of your point of
view and at the same time be like you
know back off because you don't get it
you don't understand the situation you
never will you can share an opinion but
when that opinion turns from love into
hate yeah that's the negative and weird
spewing negativity into the world when
really all we need is positive
[Music]
you